we'll just ran out of time why is it
every time I come to visit there's
always a crisis Oh inert the
scientifically impossible but we will
happen underneath understanding them
just tell me what I can do
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my new video for the flash season 6
arrow crisis on Infinite Earths there
was a whole bunch of stuff happening
yesterday people freaking out because
Tom Welling is talking about being in
the crisis episodes so I'll explain
what's going on with that there been a
lot of other really big things floating
around about like the Titans crossing
over so I'll break it all down what I
think is real what I think is not going
to happen I also have a full actual
schedule for when all the crossover
episodes are happening both before the
break and after the break too because
the breaking it into two parts like
Avengers infinity war in Avengers
endgame if you are new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
it's only going to get crazier in an
awesome way later this year and I'm
still looking for an extra special
giveaway to do for the crossover videos
this season so everyone post all your
crisis theories in the comments and
leave your suggestions for crossover
giveaways but just to be clear right now
they're still planning the story for
crisis on Infinite Earths they have some
of the really big things planned out
like the big action scenes they know
what the overarching story is going to
be but they're still casting all the
characters they haven't started shooting
it yet they won't actually start
shooting it for a little while so if
there's a bunch of actors like save from
Smallville who's agents the producers
are still negotiating with over dates
and salaries the actual story of the
crossover will change a little bit
depending on whether or not some of
those negotiations are successful they
know most of what's gonna happen with
arrow season 8 Stephen Amell sort of
signing off this is sort of his farewell
tour think of crisis on Infinite Earths
as his big going-away party so they have
most of the Stephen Amell stuff mapped
out they might change some minor things
based on new ideas they come up with for
a character moments but these are the
really big plot beats that they've
talked about that you all probably have
thought about they'd to start with a
flashback explaining who the
anti-monitor is and why he's threatening
the positive matter universe usually
that starts with an action scene where
you see him doing something terrible
then they launch into an explainer they
did the same thing with a crossover last
year opening with Barry Allen from the
flash TV show of the 90s on earth 90
with the littered bodies all over the
battlefield you see the monitor tell
them the world is doomed then they
launch into the explainer about who the
character is
they have to have a scene with the
pariah character tipping off the
crossover played by Tom Cavanagh he's
also playing pariah in addition to
reverse-flash and the new version of
Harrison wells so he's playing three
different characters during the
crossover pariah is the character in the
comics who's blamed for the anti-monitor
learning that our multiverse exists he's
sort of the person that warns everyone
during crisis kind of the same way that
Barry Allen from earth 90 did during
last year's crossover his name is mano
vu but he calls himself the monitor down
there'll be a big arc of Oliver Queen
traveling all over time and space
putting together a team to prepare for
battle with the anti-monitor and then an
early team-up battle where everyone gets
their asses handed to them by the ante
monitors forces Avengers infinity war
style remember crisis on Infinite Earths
is sort of the DC TV version of Avengers
infinity war in Avengers end game
combined in one this mega universe
shattering event so they'll have their
version of a snap sure where a big chunk
of the multiverse probably gets wiped
out by the anti-monitor then a final
battle Avengers endgame style where they
rally Oliver Queen makes his ultimate
sacrifice
Iron Man style
[Music]
and they're able to push the
anti-monitor back into the antimatter
universe there is no way that they
absolutely killed the anti-monitor
during the crossover he's way too
powerful for something like that but it
is more realistic to say that they could
just trap him and push him back into the
antimatter multiverse so that he can't
threaten them again right away then a
memorial of some kind for all the people
who died who they think died like Oliver
Queen Stephen Amell has been having a
little bit of fun messing with people
about what's actually going to happen to
Oliver at the end of this story people
feel like they have a they have a bead
on what's gonna happen I don't think
they do I've I loved reading online
theories and watching reaction videos
and hearing people opine about the show
like instead of straight-up dying to
find some other way of taking that chess
piece off the board until they want to
bring him back for another crossover in
future years like Oliver Queen living on
in the source not really dead but not
really alive more of a Yoda type
character who could just pop up anytime
he wants to we'll call that the Deep
Space nine ending - arrow like the
ascension of Oliver Queen where he's not
really alive he's not really dead either
but here are those top five really big
rumors that you've all probably been
seeing particularly the Tom Welling one
so starting with number five Tom Welling
will star as his version of Superman
Clark enter in the crossover Michael
Rosenbaum will be back as Lex and Lana
Lang so here's the reason why people
think that Tom Welling is coming back
now yesterday he was taking pictures and
video of himself shooting something in a
different part of the world someone of
course told him that they really wanted
to see him in crisis and he said duh on
the post so everyone's like wait a
minute is he messing with us is he
actually talking to the producers about
actually starring in the crossover Marc
Guggenheim said that he's been on the
phone every day with the agents of the
Smallville actors trying to get them to
come back so they're actively trying to
get these people separately people were
saying this Smallville Lex Luthor was
already confirmed for the crossover and
Michael Rosenbaum was dunking on them a
little bit like wait a minute is this
confirmed by actually the crossover what
do you think about this Jon Cryer
because right now Jon Cryer is the Mae
version of lex luthor in the arrowverse
from supergirls earth we know he's going
to be in the crossover so together they
were messing with people a little bit
Michael Rosenbaum of all the Smallville
actors has talked a lot about being
asked to come do stuff on the new DC TV
shows in turning them down but he's also
separately claimed in different
interviews that he has not been asked to
come back so he's kind of all over the
place on it I wouldn't count on him
being in the crossover Kristin Kreuk
separately who played Lana Lang has
talked about wanting to come do a cameo
in the crossover so I think that if they
can get at least two of those three
Smallville actors to come back then the
third one will also come back so if Tom
Welling sees that Lana Lang is coming
back he'll probably be more likely to
come back if Michael Rosenbaum sees that
the other two are coming back then he'll
probably come over to and say okay I'll
do a cameo and we'll do the three of us
on-screen together but regardless I
think that whatever Smallville cameo
scene that they have during the
crossover will be relatively small
because the main versions of Superman
during the crossover will be Tyler
hoechlin version in Brandon Ralph
playing the Kingdom Come Superman those
will be the much bigger more critical
roles so just expect Smallville minor
minor cameo but it is still be really
cool whatever they want to do I will
totally be cool with it
number four big rumor Lynda Carter
coming back as a version of Wonder Woman
from her TV show this is the one that I
don't think is actually gonna happen
even Marc Guggenheim said that it's
unlikely that they could get her to come
back mostly for scheduling also maybe a
little bit because Warner Brothers might
not want them to use Wonder Woman on the
TV shows because we have the Wonder
Woman movie coming out next year it's a
little bit different with Batman and
Superman because now we actually do have
a couple versions of Batman on TV being
Batman but number three big rumor the
crossover will combine a few versions of
Earth so more of the heroes are on earth
one after the crossover like combining
supergirls earth 38 with earth 1 I think
this rumor is more likely but they've
been kind of weird about doing stuff
like that in the past neither that are
shattering the multiverse in the
crossover it's a lot easier to explain
how you can retcon stuff like that and
still have it make sense
number 2 big rumor this is a brand new
one you may have seen a report that
Titans are actually going to be in the
crossover
most of the people talking about this or
the smaller blogging sites so take it
with a giant grain of salt because
titans is still in the middle of filming
their season two episodes so when
they're filming the crisis episodes in a
couple months
the Titans people will still be busy
filming their episodes for season two so
the only way they would be able to make
an actual crossover of any kind happened
would be to do it Deadpool to x-men Dark
Phoenix style what happened during that
movie is that they filmed Deadpool 2 in
Vancouver but they were filming x-men
Dark Phoenix in Toronto so what happened
is is because they wanted that funny
cameo scene where he opens the doors
they pretend to be really quiet and then
closed the doors so the Deadpool doesn't
see that they're also inside the
x-mansion but they filmed the x-men part
of that scene on a green screen in
Toronto and then just added it in
digitally to the Deadpool scene later so
if they're actually gonna be any Titans
during the crossover it's probably gonna
be a really quick cameo and it'll be
some green screen moment like that but
number one biggest rumor you probably
saw this recently the crossover will
contain a backdoor pilot for the next
new arrowverse spin-off show that
they're developing the CW recently
officially revealed that they're
developing a new DC TV show next year
but they didn't say what it would be
they did address the idea of doing a
spin-off with future team arrow more
arrow spin-offs but the president of the
CW said that it would likely be
something a little bit different so
right now best odds on that next new DC
TV show are birds-of-prey spin-off of
arrow like a new version of birds of
prey that isn't quite so hot topic for
all those you remember the last time the
CW tried to do it birds of prey TV show
a Superman family show with Tyler
hoechlin his Lois Lane and their new son
John Kent who's basically the new
version of Superboy in the comics right
now if you haven't been reading the
newer Superman comics all their
characters are coming back during the
crisis crossover and there isn't gonna
be a new Superman movie for a long time
so let me know in the comments if
they're not gonna do a direct spin-off
with the future team arrow people what
do you think that new DC TV show is
going to be next year it could very well
be a character that we've never seen
before that will debut during the
crossover like some Easter Egg that they
then turn into a separate pilot but as
we get more details about that I'll
include it in my
videos they'll be more teasers and
trailers for the crossover happening in
the next couple of months as they get
ready to start filming it but here's the
actual breakdown of the schedule for
crisis on Infinite Earths the first
episode will be Supergirl Sunday
December 8th then Batwoman Monday
December 9th then the flash on that next
Tuesday then they go on the mid-season
break they come back in January part
four is going to be arrow Tuesday
January 14th then the very last episode
of the crossover will be legends of
tomorrow right after that on that same
Tuesday night so back-to-back episodes
but remember Titans episode 1 is coming
back in a couple weeks I'll do an Easter
Egg video for that everyone click here
to watch that brand new trailer with
Batman in it and the new version of
Deathstroke and click here to learn
about Dark Avengers and the other secret
Marvel phase 5 movies that we just found
out about thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight